it's early in the morning and Martin
Engel bag is already out canvassing so
far he's getting a lukewarm response now
and then someone will stop for a quick
chat and say something encouraging and
passing like I'm voting for you anyway
or looking good but it's too early in
the morning for in-depth political
discussions but they're right it is
looking pretty good for Engelberg he's
with the Sebastian courts list as the
conservative Austrian People's Party or
ovp is named on the ballot it's
currently leading in the polls the
election campaign is entering its
critical phase there's a festive
atmosphere at the Venus tateleh arena
where 10,000 have gathered to see
Sebastian courts Martin Engelberg has
brought his kids along Sebastian Kurtz
was probably the first top politician
who actually talked with me we've had
frequent conversations he really gives
you the feeling that he's listening to
you and picks up on your ideas
and there he is the star of the event
Sebastiaan cords is showing the crowd
who's boss just as he did when he took
the helm of the ovp earlier this year
the party was in disarray when he took
over and he wasted no time firing senior
officials including some regional
governors all that matters is the result
on October the 15th lowering taxes
improving education and limiting
emigration these are the issues
underpinning his campaign but even
within his own party there are rumblings
that kourt's is more concerned with
power than policy Erhart Bozek an OPP
stalwart and former vice chancellor is
sceptical of the cult of personality
surrounding corpses campaigns it's a
general problem in politics and
specifically the OBP and is a bastion
cost list what do they actually stand
for what do they want what is their
agenda there are many open questions
after years of a consensus seeking grand
coalition many in Austria appear to want
strong leadership and a clear message
courts recognized this and seized his
opportunity but he's playing a
high-stakes game courts replaced the
normal selection process for the ovp
candidates and replaced it with a list
of independent candidates such as Martin
Engelberg many are surprised to see
anger burger psychiatrist an art
collector through his lot in with courts
it can't be ruled out that his party
ends up entering into a coalition with
the far-right freedom party angle bag as
an active member of Vienna's Jewish
community in the past he's rejected this
option but now he appears to be changing
tack of course I would prefer it if the
coalition partner were not the freedom
party my argument is that the more vote
we get as the Sebastian Kurtz list the
less we'll see of the freedom party in
the new government
Martin Engelberg looks likely to soon be
a member of parliament along with the
Austrian People's Party is young beacon
of hope